l'île de france a attiré 46,7 millions
de touristes en 2015 un secteur majeur
dans le cadre du rapprochement entre les
yvelines et les hauts-de-seine et cela à
travers une politique commune sur la
stratégie du développement du tourisme
des deux territoires
on a défini huit axes de travail qui
sombra pas les rappeler les huit mais il
ya ce que je veux dire le tourisme rural
le tourisme d'affaires le tourisme
hôteliers le tourisme patrimonial et
c'est le tourisme de la scène huit
priorités choisies après un travail
lancé en septembre dernier les membres
de la commission tourisme de le pays
yvelines hauts de seine ont rencontré
près de 150 professionnels du tourisme
pour connaître leurs attentes
le premier objectif c'était déjà de
faire un diagnostic de je dirais de la
complémentarité qu'il peut y avoir entre
le 78 92 avec versailles avec bien sûr
notre axe seine qui est quelque chose de
fondamental
et puis du côté du 92 également avec la
défense qui est un lieu aussi d'un
développement touristique d'affaires qui
est fondamental important avec ses deux
pôles touristiques les deux
collectivités partagent aussi la scène
un site stratégique pour développer des
activités pour les visiteurs nationaux
et internationaux avec en ligne de mire
le développement économique
ce potentiel simplement il doit être mis
en cohérence avoir une politique
d'ensemble pour le promouvoir
on voit bien que paris est saturé
d'ailleurs et donc il ya vraiment un
champ là qui est tout à fait important
producteur aussi d'emplois et de
croissance
il est normal que l'ouest parisien
cherche à récupérer à capitaliser sur
cette richesse cette stratégie
interdépartementale et portait sur
quatre ans entre 2017 et 2021
un point d'étape sur cette politique
sera effectué lors d'une assemblée en